you've said you know man i would love to
put out an album of country music you
love country music you've covered
country tunes you love johnny cash and
it's like don't you think in a way the
reason you're not doing that is because
you got to sit and worry i'm on a roll i
got a lot of money people behind me i
got a tour i got this and that i mean to
be honest there's nothing stopping me
from
taking a camera or
uh setting up in my studio in utah and
just recording a country album and me
just putting it on [ __ ] youtube
there's nothing stopping me like yeah
maybe i'll face some repercussions
afterwards from the label and [ __ ] but
it's like there's nothing stopping me
from doing that like i'm allowed to do
that so why do you think you don't i am
happily obligated to do concerts and
and show love to my fans and go and sing
these songs for my fans and then i'm
happily obligated to
write music and make beats by myself and
i'm happily obligated to
um you know take care of my family and
take care of everybody
and so it's just it's it's a lot of time
and it's about
finding that space to a lot that time
so if we get another like if i get
another year to myself maybe i'll make a
[ __ ] country album